while president biden's white house
pushes new covid mandates liberals and
democrats get to play by a different set
of rules former virginia democratic
governor terry mcauliffe got caught
flouting federal regulations by going
mask-less on an amtrak train and
journalist glenn greenwald is tearing
into aoc and maskless met gala celebs
with a scathing article quote
it is now commonplace to see two
distinct classes of people those who
remain masculist as they are served and
those who they employ as their servants
who must have their faces covered at all
times the pandemic
generated a new form of crude cultural
segregation a series of protocols which
ensure that mask-less elites need not
ever cast eyes upon the faces of their
servant class
wow that was a very eloquent
put-down greg do you know that i own a
pair of mask-less chaps
i never want to see that the good news
is with servants uh wearing masks you
don't have to hear about their
screenplay right
but if you ever and greenwald is right
if you ever wanted to see kind of like a
better image of have-nots serving the
haves just look at the met gala it's the
slaves you know obeying their masters
they wear the masks you don't and the
masks tell you the power structure right
you go like okay if
the people not wearing the mask they're
important they're celebrities people
wearing the masks they have to do it or
they're going to lose their job so it's
it's like even the um aoc's dress
i don't even care about that dress in
fact i might argue that was pretty that
was really cool for going in there but
the problem is nobody there was made
uncomfortable by it because they think
it oh wow that's so beautiful yeah we'll
pay more taxes because we're like
billionaires so what what what would
have been more interesting is dresses
that say things that would have made
them uncomfortable like you know um i'm
against the death penalty unless it's an
unborn child oh you know something that
would just be you know something that
would that would like make people go oh
my god you know but they didn't that's a
safe that's a safe message i think you
should wear a dress to the gala next
year i wore that same dress at the
oscars last year you just don't remember
no no one could see you
dana this we saw this again remember
there was that nancy pelosi fundraiser
when everybody was drinking chardonnay
again the servers masked and everybody
else unmatched you see it if you walk up
to your neighborhood which is the fancy
one in town yeah you mean the lower east
side yeah right oh yes
you walk up there and you any restaurant
that you go that you go by
everybody is sitting there eating at
these fancy restaurants and all the
staff is having to wear a mess now
restaurant workers were given the
opportunity to have vaccines they were
amongst the first and i'm assuming that
many of them are vaccinated and yet they
still have to do this plus i don't
understand this whole thing they want
everyone to get vaccinated i want people
to get vaccinated got vaccinated i was
really glad when we could then go
shopping
without having to wear a mask yesterday
i go to a fancy department store in
jesse's neighborhood
and i'm walking in and i immediately
felt uncomfortable because like wait am
i
what wait why is everyone wearing a mask
again i don't understand i think that
the vaccination rate in new york is sky
high and there's this little sign that
says even if you're vaccinated we just
ask you please wear a mask well guess
what
i'm not shopping there anymore right
exactly i will shop online they just
lost a lot of business and i mean a lot
of businesses
have never been sober for that reason
restoration i have a bar on the roof and
i and they said they said we needed our
passports and i like my wife doesn't
vaccinate by the way you made a great
i'm sorry i'm hijacking you made a great
point as a pregnant woman
what's the percentage of women who want
to get pregnant and are pregnant who
don't have the vaccine uh 75 have not
had the vaccine so they can't go with
their husband to a restaurant
some husbands might think that's a good
thing
with the amount that we eat i can tell
you it's cutting down
it's economical inflation is the kicker
your thoughts uh a couple of thoughts
there was a piece in the atlantic very
early on in the pandemic that was
particularly meaningful and it was
written by a guy who checks out people
at the grocery store and he said i don't
want to be a hero i have to have this
job
like when we were all standing out on
our balconies like you were saying
yesterday it's seven o'clock and they
became
essential workers and the heroes of the
pandemic and they did do incredible
things they kept us fed clothes etc
doing all these deliveries um but it was
the beginning of creating another level
of an underclass and they weren't the
doctors who were saving us in the
hospitals they were the guy who was
giving us our tofu
and it's a power move yeah it's a power
move it's also a safety concern and i
just want to say on top of it for
that a it's become part of the uniform
and that people who serve do wear
uniforms and that's something that just
exists but we have seen and this was in
the monmouth pole from today an amazing
turn of events that we had 24 percent of
people said that they wouldn't get
vaccinated absolutely in january that's
down to only 15 today so the mandates
and the enforcement of masking is
helping getting people to the goal which
is herd immunity and that we can all be
safer if we're vaccinated okay there is
a a place in rye where i live in
westchester county
uh what
fancy place okay well as the governor
has lifted the mass mandate some of our
staff choose to wear masks some of them
don't when you come in you don't have to
show proof of vaccination you can wear a
mask or you don't have to so they're
saying everybody's free to do whatever
they want we ask our guests to respect
our employees personal and private
health choices and any further
discussion will not be allowed
no just no exceptions
good for the ride bar and grill they're
saying you know what everybody's free to
do what they want it's right near the
train station people go in they get
hamburgers salads whatever they want and
they're saying look we don't even want
to hear it if you want to complain about
this one or that one and the judge will
be appearing at the bar tonight won't
you john yes yes i will
i'm on the seven o'clock show
and i want everybody to know that a
couch or a bed from restoration hardware
where greg shops is like thirty thousand
dollars i know
we gotta go
up next facebook under fire over a new
report that shows just how destructive
the social media giant can be do you get
a discount
[Music]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else